how you use your voice is really
important and it's really driven by
context more than anything else so if
you and your tone of voice will
immediately begin to impact somebody's
mood and then at this immediately how
their brain function says it's actually
scientific data out there now that shows
us that our brains will work up to 31
percent more effectively if we're in a
good mood so if I smile at you and you
see it or you can hear a smile on
someone's voice if I automatically smile
it at you and you can hear that I like
you I will actually be able to reach
into your brain flip the positive switch
put you in a better mood they're mirror
neurons in our brain that we have no
control over they automatically respond
and if I intentionally put you in a good
mood your brain will be working more
effectively and that already begins to
increase the chances that you're gonna
collaborate me with me you'll be smarter
and you like me more at the same time
now I'll put in downward inflection
downward inflection is often used to say
you know this is the way it is there's
no other way and I will say it exactly
like that if there's a term in a
contract that there's no movement on and
I want you to know it and feel it
without me having to say there's no
movement on this which you know maybe
you want to yell at somebody and that
that's ineffective because that triggers
a different part of the brain and makes
people angry and they want to fight and
I've done this in contract negotiations
I've said things like we don't do work
for hire just like that
well that's the other side no there's no
movement whatsoever I also may need to
put you in a more collaborative frame of
mind and if I want to if I want to ask
you a question I'll say something like
it seems like this is important to you
and I looked up it's more driven by
context and I can use upward inflection
to encourage you and smile while I'm
questioning you and that'll make you
feel less attacked by being questioned
because be
were made to feel a little bit defensive
when they're questioned anyway so if I
know if I have to question you if I want
you to think about a different option
that I'm going to be as encouraging as
possible while I may be very assertive
at the same time the mirroring that I
teach is not the same as the way most
people think of marrying most people
when they think of marrying they think
mirror and body language mirror and tone
of voice even using the same words it's
not that at all the mirroring that I
teach is much more simplistic and
interestingly enough has a great impact
on how the other person interacts with
you and it's just repeating the last one
two three words that they've said word
for word one two three words or it's
repeating a selected one two three words
and what it really does is it helps
connect people's thoughts there will
almost never be a time when you've
mirrored the last three words of what
someone said when they want to go on and
explain and reward and expand and that
mirror what it's just done is it helped
give you a better understanding what the
other person is trying to say it also
gives you more time to think it's a way
to buy time and a negotiation for
yourself the other person doesn't see
you buying time in any way shape or form
it's a great way when you don't know
what to say of where to go to keep them
talking in a way that they're very
comfortable with one of my clients
actually mirrors his counterparts
positions every single time every time
they stated make a statement on a
position he simply mirrors it they'll
repeat it they'll expand it and every
time he does that it also gives them a
good feel for whether or not they're
really stable in that position or
whether there's quite a bit of softness
in a position completely based on how
they reward and respond to his mirror so
Mir is a great way to keep somebody else
talking very comfortably the f-word in
negotiations is fair fair is the f-bomb
and when you begin to look for it and
it's stunning and how many negotiations
somebody drops the f-bomb in the
negotiation and when somebody says we
just want what's fair that's actually a
really bad sign one of two things is
going on now the cutthroat negotiators
know how much I can punch your buttons
if I say I've given you a fair offer and
that will immediately put you on the
defensive and make you worry about
whether or not you're being fair and
most people have an instinctive feeling
about fair price fair market fair is
just like this incredibly overused term
in negotiations I just want what's fair
what's the fair market price so if I say
I've given you a fair offer and I'm
using you being unfair I've immediately
knocked you back on your heels it's a
way for me to gain an advantage on you
if I'm that kind of a negotiator the
flip side of it is maybe I've been
assertive enough in the negotiations and
I haven't been using enough tactical
empathy that the other person feels like
I'm taking taking taking from them and
they'll respond with I just want what's
fair that maybe someone genuinely
telling me very indirectly that they
feel I've been far too aggressive and if
they feel I've been aggressive and if
they feel treated unfairly one of two
things is going to happen they're either
gonna walk away from a great deal or
they're gonna make implementation
painful you know when implementation of
a negotiation is painful when they drag
their feet when they don't make
deadlines when they don't deliver the
product quality they're supposed to
deliver when they're not as thorough and
paying as much attention to detail
because they didn't feel it was a fair
deal that destroy your profit so you
have to really keep an eye out for the
f-bomb in negotiations and when somebody
else feels they've been treated unfairly
they're probably gonna hurt you over it